[Music]
let's go
to anna who joins us in olympia
washington anna how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call i
wanted to get your input on trying to
balance kind of they'll live for today
attitude with long-term paying off debt
and
savings goals i'm an emergency medicine
doctor and
you know see people who have sudden
death or i walk in a room and diagnose
somebody with cancer out of the blue and
so i have this kind of
you know perspective that that i don't
really know how long
myself or my family members have and so
balancing that
live for today versus you know paying
off medical school data et cetera just
hoping to get your perspective
yeah that's a very interesting
interesting perspective that you have
it's kind of in your face all the time
so i've spent
right um several years researching and
walking alongside
doctors and the mental health of doctors
okay
and one of the things that is and
same with lawyers same with preachers
obviously i grew up in the home of a
homicide detective
and one of the the the bellwether
moments for me was when i realized
that those who who
work in the pain of other peoples for a
living
over time their bell curve begins to
shift
and so i've got this funny there's a
it's a funny family story that wasn't
funny at the time now it's funny
um i was a kid my dad took me to
baseball practice i was like 10. i was
in this
suburban north houston little community
the worst thing i ever knew that
happened is somebody spray painted
something on somebody right i mean
nothing big
and i left the back door open standing
wide open we went to baseball practice
behind the fence a fence that was locked
we got home and my dad looked at me and
he said
the door's open and he
went he proceeded to clear the room
as though it was a police scene as it
was a military scene
and i remember being nine or ten and we
laughed about this now i remember being
nine or ten thinking
that's a bit much you know what i mean
but here's the thing
yeah a hundred percent of his day was
dealing with things that statistically
never happened to anybody except it does
right so fast forward to your situation
you're a doctor who all day every day
what you do
is you go into people's this is never
going to happen to me and you tell them
but it happened to you and over time
that's that secondary trauma weighs you
down it begins to
infiltrate the way you see the world it
it think of it as bricks in a backpack
it begins to lean you over too
you're not hurting but you're
experiencing other people's pain all day
long
all day long all day long and it begins
to shift the way you see the world
it's a new pair of glasses it makes you
think what does it even matter
i could just get hit by a car on the way
out of here and there's a gift to that
you know how precious life is most
people don't
and there's a weight to that which is
you could get hit by a car and you
probably won't
and so i've lived in that same thing
working in crisis working hard
conversations with folks day after day
after day for year after year after year
and the way i balance that is
recognizing
it could and so i'm prepared for the it
could but also living like
it probably won't because it probably
won't does that make sense
yeah yeah is there i'm just curious
anna is there a specific area of tension
where you're going i
i'm i'm busting it right now maybe give
us a little bit more detail about where
this tension
it's it's a really brilliant question
and i think john diagnosed it
beautifully but i'm just curious where's
the practical tension for you right now
well um as you guys know the training is
long so i mean i
i was gazelle intense with my entire
life for like seven years and
and the loans and and the money became
like this idea of monopoly money so
when i came out i was probably negative
900k
with my doctor house my two cars all my
student loans and it really didn't mean
anything and then there was this weight
after a few years on me of you know what
is weighing me down
and when i actually looked at it was
like oh my god if something happens to
me
my whole family's life is going to be
destroyed and so working
back to like you know get debt paid down
get that paid down but just after
a while it's like okay do i not go on
vacations with my kids just with that
that enormous amount of debt you know
that's going to take a decade to pay off
do i put off those vacations with my
kids do i work more
to make more money to get the shovel
bigger to pay it off
when you know again i have these
experiences where i'm taking care of
pediatric cancer patients or a 40 year
old woman who comes in bed you know that
was totally healthy that is my
same age and so it just the the idea
of putting vacations off missing their
ball games to work more
all that even though i know you know
yeah i need to get out of bed it's just
it's hard to trade that
you know you're exhausted yeah you're
exhausted i mean that's let's just own
that
are you uh double income one income
what's the situation
uh i'm just one income my my spouse
stays home to
uh to stay at home with the kids and um
what's your name situation right now
yeah i get it and i think that's great
what's your
about half i've yeah i've got i've got
it down by about half i'm about
um 400 still in debt with my house
and student loans okay so let's take the
house out of it yeah how much loan
how much how much in student loan about
a hundred and twenty
okay you are gazelle intense for 120
more and then you're gonna go on a
vacation
got it yeah seriously yeah we even
we even have separate baby steps for
each one of those things
credit card debt and yeah what i'm
saying like
and you can knock that out you're you're
what an emergency room
doctor yeah yeah yeah
yes you can crush that 120. and then
chill relax on the house so we put the
house
in baby step six right okay and we do
that on purpose
so you're a lot closer than you realize
and
and i also think that you've paid enough
off
are you guys not taking vacations is
that where you really are you've not
taken vacations in years
no no we have but then i have this guilt
of like oh that money could have gone
toward the debt you know and my student
loans
are you know low two percent and would
and would go away if i die so it's kind
of like well
is my priority paying off my house so if
something happens to me
my my young kids and my spouse will have
somewhere to live and my
student loans go away you know this is
just a strange situation
yeah you know what john on this
situation i mean okay i'm trying to sit
here i hear what she's saying you paid
off 500 grand so far
yeah yeah go go on vacation yes i i
think now you've got the point where
a you know how to budget and you can
live a normal life and you're still
knocking these loans out
right you do not yeah we tell gazelle
intense for people that are in i mean
first of all we want everybody to be
gazelle intense
but that i i think there's some
relativism to this it's like you've
knocked out the credit cards in the cars
and you're not swimming anymore in debt
you you are in a situation where with
your income
you are gonna knock this out i'm not
saying you're not intense
but to translate gazelle intensity in
your situation to
we're not gonna go on vacation and i'm
never going to see a lot of kids
i don't think that's your situation i
take a deep breath and enjoy life
and keep being disciplined and doc let
me tell you this
um man i'm going to go speak to medical
school in the fall so i'm going to be as
direct with you as i will with those
students okay
you're brilliant you you wouldn't be
entrusted with the lives of others if
you weren't
and so let me say it this way this is
not a math problem
this isn't an interest rate problem this
is an inflammatory response problem
this is an existential problem this is a
weight that you carry
all of the time problem yep and so you
can justify the
the even your language my family would
be destroyed you know what they wouldn't
they'd have to rent a house or a
one-bedroom apartment
but they wouldn't be destroyed yeah
right and that is the language of
secondary
trauma right that's an exhausted person
who helps other people for a living
and then goes home and has to be a mom
too and so
you've got to got to take care of
yourself
at some point afterwards guys i really
appreciate it after sprinting for seven
years nine
twelve years you're gonna run out of gas
and this that car is gonna stop in the
road yeah you probably should go talk to
somebody
go start taking care of yourself take
care of your family knock that 120 out
and then
whoo breathe next month's budget let's
move it around a little bit and let's
put a little
little day spa appointment in there you
know i only made three or four of those
five or six of those well i was just
starting her out
just getting her started to relax i love
it